so uh we have a funny story as i pertain
to defund the police
melissa milano oh boy she called the
cops
she she's tweeted uh uh kind of a lot
about defunding the police and she like
apparently tweeted out a petition
telling people like join me in defunding
the police and hashtag defund the police
a small teenager was near her
neighborhood
simply shooting squirrels with an air
gun which is kind of weird
i mean like that but anyway you didn't
do that tim you go around killing
squirrels in
your neighborhood well i mean is an
airsoft gun gonna
hurt oh was it an airsoft gun or like
because i know bb guns are sometimes
called air guns right
so it was just airsoft yeah as it it was
it was an airsoft right they take its
eye out that's double check
they say air gun yeah you never actually
know okay if they're saying air gun that
could be like a 22 pellet comp like
barrel i mean i think that is because
she's
apparently she heard the shots and she
got scared yeah and i don't think an
airsoft gun
would make a loud enough noise like
little plastic pellets
yeah probably not yeah why why why was
he shooting squirrels or maybe she heard
the noises of the squirrels screaming
out in agony
and that's what scared her i think we
should keep an eye on this kid you know
yeah i know i hear that something about
we should call a social worker for them
yeah well i mean quite literally they
should have well no that is a problem
because a kid had an air gun
yeah but so she calls the cops and now
people are calling her a hypocrite
because she's all about defund the
police right
and this was a kid who was shooting
squirrels
which is really weird i don't know i
mean people are normal it's kind of a
contextual thing because like if you
were if you were hunting small game in
the woods with an air gun
that wouldn't be weird but like i guess
he is just going through his
neighborhood like i guess shooting
shooting squirrels with an airgun is not
totally unheard of or like crazy but to
do it in your neighborhood is maybe kind
of a weird thing to do yeah i don't know
if it was in his neighborhood apparently
he was like walking around various
properties
that's weird that's pretty weird yeah
that's pretty weird but so weird so mate
i'll tell you what man do you think she
was justified in calling the police if
she heard a loud shot and saw somebody
carrying a long gun yes
yeah that's that's that's a good
question it depends on like what kind of
air gun we're talking here if it was
really obvious it was a toy
then maybe not i i definitely understand
it especially if you didn't know the
parents
but you know a situation like that can
get out of hand and if you're against
police intervention and virtually
everything and you think folks need to
be solving their problems on their own
obviously there's like a bit of
hypocrisy there
i'll be fair to her though so she has
this tweet where when she was talking
about defunding the police
she posts a photo of an mrap and she
says we've militarized the police
so could it be that i i think i agree
with that by the way
right i do too i do too so that's why
you know i want to i want to make sure
i'm being fair to listen
and it's not i i think yeah i think she
was justified in calling the cops
if she's a high-profile individual and
someone's walking around with a weapon
yeah
and i think it's not necessarily
hypocritical to say that police have
been militarized in many areas they
shouldn't have been yeah
and then to want to call a couple
sheriffs to come and deal with someone
walking around your property who's on
with a long gun yeah i think that's fair
the bigger problem with this story is
how defund the police doesn't mean
anything
also true define defund the police
because what it sounds like is i don't
like the way that guy runs
so i want to take his shoes away well to
punish him and make him and somehow
that's going to make him a better runner
well defund the cops right exactly
exactly and and i think the talking
point you used to hear
was that we need to train the police
more properly or better
which is something i would agree with uh
i don't know how that's compatible with
defunding
the police exactly uh one of my best
buds he's uh he's a former police
officer
and he also served in the military in
both iraq and afghanistan
so he told me and again this is his
experience this is anecdotal
but i mean he told me based on his
experience and how well he was trained
with a firearm
most police officers were not that great
a shot and didn't train with their
handguns often enough
i've heard that yeah so i i've actually
was i was actually told something really
scary once in new york
by somebody with uh i'll just call it a
source who had knowledge of the nypd
they didn't work for the nypd
they worked in a legal capacity and they
had done uh litigation with the police
they said this
they're like you ever see fight club no
you've never seen it's been spoiled for
me though so
that's fine there's a scene where um the
main character
i guess edward norton's character we
call him jack he's on a plane and he's
explaining how he works as like this
insurance
like cost prevention or whatever is i
don't know cost analysis guy
he said if the cost of the lawsuits
are less basically the idea is if
lawsuits are more expensive
than the actual i don't know they won't
recall a car if it kills people
if they can save money that's just
exactly so i'm like i'm forgetting need
a formula and i'm trying to
trying to say it i can't do it but the
general idea was this so i saw this guy
and he said you ever seen fight club and
i was like for sure and he goes okay
if the cost of training police is more
expensive than the cost of the lawsuits
they don't train the police wow so when
the cops go out because
he's like how often do cops actually use
their firearms
rarely very rare very rarely very rare
so if they're going to train every
single cop properly and have them re-up
and do all the stuff
and they rarely ever use the gun that
seems like a big waste of money for the
city
now if they go off and they have to use
it and they fire randomly because they
don't know how to actually use it they
hit a bunch of people how much we got to
pay
training all the cops could cost 50
million the lawsuits cost 30.
we don't train the cops that's
fascinating i got to clarify that i
didn't think about that he didn't work
for the police
exactly like litigation that's what i'm
saying it's fascinating yeah i can't
can't firm or deny that but it's
certainly interesting i know that
um so a number of my police officers a
number of my uncles were police officers
on the south side of chicago
and one thing they would complain about
was the fact that defense attorneys will
also tell their clients in many
circumstances to just file a plane
a complaint against a police officer
whether or not it's valid because it can
be easier to get them out of trouble
and if you get enough of your clients to
accuse enough police officers then the
accusations start to build up and each
accusation becomes more credible and
it's much easier for you as a defense
attorney or a criminal defense attorney
to do your job
think about uh activists that do that
it's like hey accuse that guy of
whatever so that we can get him fired
exactly take his job away to stable to
destabilize the department yeah like the
supreme court
yeah so there's a viral tweet where
they're talking about the supreme court
and someone said something like
25 percent of the supreme court have
have credible
accusations against them yeah what is
incredible incredible whatever yeah
and i'm like i accuse you of stealing my
orange yeah good sir i grumph then
that's actually true i did steal an
orange
dirty dirty yeah yeah i know it's insane
well so you confess yeah no the point is
like i can accuse you of
anything i i sir i accuse you of tping a
tree in front of my house
and you're like what that's ridiculous
it doesn't matter yeah doesn't matter
unless that accused you well one problem
i think is that people that do false
accusations
uh they don't get in much trouble
afterwards i mean they make it in a
little but like if someone falsely
accuses you of murder and you have to go
through
you know the ringer and then it turns
out i was wrong i don't get charged for
murder
yeah exactly the punishment yeah well
and that's the thing part of it's
complicated because like when you look
at christine blaise ford for example
when when i made my comment what i'm not
trying to get at is that
she was necessarily lying but the
evidence really does not hold up
what she's saying it's possible she was
confused as possible she didn't have ill
will but the people who are running
with it we're clearly running with it
for reasons of political convenience
nah man nah you don't think so dude she
she said she was scared to fly and then
she was asked do you fl like you flew to
these island vacations she's like yes so
you think she was just lying
my personal opinion um yeah okay yeah i
just want to give her the benefit of the
doubt but the point is the accusations
against kavanaugh held no water
listen it's it's it's amazing how many
people are scared to just say she's a
liar conservatives from those right have
no problem doing it but it's like
come on dude 30 year old allegation she
didn't know where it was she didn't know
how she got there she had no witnesses
nothing backed her up
no i agree i agree with all that no one
agree even her friends were like what is
she talking about yeah no
like i was so traumatized i installed
the second door to my home and then they
were like actually that was the airbnb
you you set up yeah
i'm actually traumatized and scared to
fly do you fly yes
did you fly recently yes how far did you
fly thousands of miles
you're flying on cross country trail
like she like flew to like new zealand
or something i don't know exactly where
she flew but it's like
how how is that she's able to say these
things and no one did an investigation
because it's clear that she's lying no i
mean i'm just giving her an extreme
benefit of the doubt i
all of that's very compelling and i
understand where you're coming from and
again i agree that the accusations were
like you said contradicted by the
evidence i'm just i'm just careful to
call anybody a liar that's that's a good
point that's a good point
um she could be uh unwell yeah
that that was mostly my thought is that
she's a mentally ill person and
i've and i've i've been saying this a
lot man that uh antiva prays upon these
people
there's actually a really interesting
story we got to talk about i cover
i talked about this on my 1 pm segment
there you know what gang stalking is
no no gang stalking is this paranoid
delusion that people have
where they think like operatives or
agents are always spying on them
interesting and they'll think you're a
spy they'll like you'll meet them and
they'll be like they'll look at you in
the like
are you one of them say yes or no oh and
you'll be like uh excuse me you are
yeah so they actually really they tell
their friends and family
like you know someone spying on me and
they'll say where like there's a camera
in my house i'm telling you it's in the
light i know it's there
they think around every corner there's
an agent or an operative the new york
times wrote about this and what's really
interesting is that
uh they talk about how after 9 11 this
like skyrocketed this view
of agents and gang stalking and they use
the internet to find
like-minded people who experience the
same thing to form collectives
to take action over a shared delusion
even though they all contradict each
other it seems to make no sense wow
what's interesting about this is that
when you take that concept
after 9 11 all these people thought they
were being spotted by the government
patriot act and i say all that stuff
right now you have
in the mainstream media all this talk
about fascists and white supremacists
and what do we get
fascists are stalking me i'm not even
i'm not even exaggerating no no i
believe it
it was jonathan k of quillette who
tweeted about this and i thought it was
it was really insight it was collect i
was like
i didn't even never thought about that
because they had this woman who was
claiming that someone broke into her car
and it was clearly a white supremacist
who was harassing her and stalking her
because she's an activist
and tons of other people started
tweeting the same things yes they're
stalking me and harassing me
then you look at what andy noah does
right andy no covers the people who get
arrested he covers the protests and the
riots
and he says like this person got
arrested for felony arson blah blah blah
and then they start saying that he's
feeding he's feeding the white
supremacists our information and it
it's gang stalking it's the same thing
they think that the person
around the corner is a fascist they're
everywhere they literally think there's
millions of people
it sounds like a shared paranoid
delusion these people are experiencing
there are no white supremacists there's
like
in this country of 328 million there's
estimated
like a high estimate is like 11 000
according to like the defamation league
or
you know uh some of these organizations
so you they're not stalking you
they're they just but they believe it so
you have you have antifa targeting
people who are unwell
who think these things are true using
them
to do things to benefit them convincing
them to commit crimes convincing them to
hurt people
and they go around and they do it
they're justified because they all share
this delusion
so if someone says i swear oh fascist
was following me me too
that it must be true isn't that that one
guy uh that
killed the dude uh you know what i'm
talking about the uh the guy was wearing
a maga hat or something
oh he said my friend was in danger i had
to kill him and i was surrounded i was
surrounded there were cars
with that guy that guy michael reinel he
said to vice news
that there were cars all around with
trump supporters with weapons that dude
was one of the he probably had one of
these like
paranoid delusion of gang stalking
things people that think they've been
abducted by aliens also
are experiencing that some kind of
paranoid delusional psychosis or
whatever
and then here's what happens you get
someone who's sitting there shaking
being like they're everywhere and you go
they are
but they're not agents they're actually
fascists they are yeah trust me i see
them too
you're the only one who believes me
that's right come with me take this now
throw it at that building
and they do and then guess who gets
arrested not the guy who handed the
explosive
the guy who threw the explosive they
used these people
and so you know we're talking about
christine blasey ford
i'm not for all we know that she was
just
a she's an unwell person wow and they
were like it really did happen
don't you remember it did she look it it
did and then when they actually
scrutinized her and she didn't have
people telling her
she's just like i don't know i don't
remember i don't know
no all the witnesses denied it
ultimately i think she was just lying i
mean that's a simple solution right
like look occam's razor suggests the
simple
simple solution tends to be the correct
one that is that's not a law that's just
something people point out
it doesn't necessarily mean that in
every circumstance you can say it's true
it doesn't mean you ever actually
mathematically tested it because you
can't really
but it is an idea that i think most of
us agree upon
don't take things too far it's probably
just you know
more simple than that simple solution
here is just lied
they want to stop brett kavanaugh by any
means necessary they accused him he was
already vetted
right yeah so uh brett kavanaugh was a
federal judge which means he went
through the vetting process in the
confirmation process
they were going through it again and
then all of a sudden 30 year old
vague nebulous stories start popping up
but it's also possible that they were
both
18 and blackout drunk and she vaguely
that's not what she's getting forced
i don't think she said they were drunk
right i don't remember i don't i don't
remember all the specifics
she said that quite a while i just
remember there wasn't a lot of evidence
and the media was completely on her side
yeah yeah it's ridiculous she she said
that she was at a party at someone's
house
and brett kavanaugh and his friend were
like they were like we went upstairs and
she went with them
and then he pinned her on the bed and
jumped on top of her and then she was
like panicking and then his friend
jumped on him and they rolled over and
then she got up and ran away that was it
and then from that what did we get
accusations that brett kavanaugh
was contributing to
drugging women and keeping them in rooms
where men would line up outside the door
taking turns and it's like
yeah and then and then they held up a
picture of him making a really icky face
when he was called a rapist for several
hours and like look at this man's face
yeah
does this look like the face of a man
who isn't a rapist like that
was kind of what they were going on that
was the face plastered on everything
i mean it was it was him like crying
yeah it was his face like he was about
to cry
which is reasonable but they make it
look like he's snarling
geez man thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you